consider a time in your life when you
did something that was so immensely
embarrassing that you felt like the
world would never take you seriously
again think of a time when a friend
partner or family member did something
that hurt you so deeply that it made you
question the meaning of human connection
reflect on a time when you failed at
something that you tried so incredibly
hard to accomplish that you felt you
would never be able to move on and feel
good about yourself again
now observe yourself right now how do
you feel do you still feel any of those
ways right now because of those moments
would you have been thinking about those
moments if I hadn't just reminded you of
them perhaps you're able to find a
lingering memory of them somewhere in
the recesses of your subconscious mind
but the feelings associated with them
have lost most if not all of their
weight on your current state of being
your feelings of happiness sadness
excitement stress love hate and
everything in between have all since
reset you've moved on you have since
experienced new moments that have buried
the old what you are once transfixed on
certain that life was ruined because of
is now simply a blurry memory this is
because you are a human and you're
forced to move on whether you like it or
not as passengers aboard the train of
time we are forced to leave moments and
occurrences behind us this can be sad
when fun and beautiful things happen but
it is liberating when bad things happen
to us or because of us leaving moments
behind us is not to say that the moments
of our past don't affect and mold who we
are
and who we will become but it is to say
that they no longer solely control how
we feel right now
and likewise despite how good or bad or
intense this moment feels right now it
too will matter very little to our
future self no moment lasts forever and
as such no feeling lasts forever we will
without doubt experience more sadness
embarrassment failure stress and
mean-spiritedness in the future but we
will also experience more happiness
wonder pleasure love and positivity
these new moments will require our
energy and attention and as a result the
feelings associated with the moments of
the past will dissolve into
insubstantiality
right now things may feel dismal perhaps
you made a big mistake at work perhaps
you were going through a fight with a
friend or a partner or perhaps you have
done something really foolish in front
of a lot of people whatever it may be
the feeling of it will only last a short
period of time eventually there will be
something new that you have to concern
yourself with and this thing you are
worried about right now
will no longer matter no single moment
defines who you are or how you will
experience life time will carry you on
word and you will always adapt to the
fluctuations of life and return to your
Center and so therefore every time you
experience something negative despite
how much it may seem like it at the time
it most likely isn't going to ruin your
life and you can take it a little less
seriously
thank you for watching if he found
enjoyment and value in this video please
give it a thumbs up share your thoughts
in the comments below and if you are not
already be sure to subscribe to our
channel we are constantly coming out
with new videos to help you experience
life with clarity and Wonder